gorgeous start to the morning of course
with daylight savings time the sun's not
getting up for about another half hour
that pre-dawns early light we talked to
would like to talk about maybe a breeze
or two out there at red rock resort now
the official temperature is 51 but some
readings now in the mid 40s so it's
going to be a chilly one you're walking
the dog or whatever up in the aliante 46
air force base you're at 47.
low 50s just about everywhere else and
way down south anthem and seven hills
you guys are at 47 so a jacket is going
to be a good idea we'll get that bus
stop forecast rounded up for you in our
next half hour meantime to nevada and
beyond now this cold front that we've
been following marching on shore in the
northern and central california is
definitely affecting reno with very
strong wind that's actually pumping up
the temperature with a mixture of rain
and snow in the higher elevations 52 new
for reno tonopah much cooler at 34. 42s
over the hump in prep and in sandy
valley as well good morning to laughlin
with your 54 kingman you're at 39 of
course cooler in cedar city at 28.
now we were going for 72 for the high
yesterday didn't quite make it got it to
69 degrees if we make 80 today it'll be
the first 80 degree day of the year
about 10 degrees above normal we've been
down to 50. that's exactly normal for
this time of year and again the sun
staying up until about 6 45 this evening
area of high pressure being pushed
slowly to the east now all of that
storminess it is staying to the north of
us we will see some high clouds and
breezes you got family friends across
the country down in the deep south
strong storms racing from east texas
through arkansas louisiana mississippi
and alabama let's get your eight day
forecast going after 80 today if we get
that far
maybe taking it down a degree or two to
78 and definitely very windy in some
parts of southern nevada tomorrow should
be great for st patrick's day on
thursday 73 more clouds over the weekend
pumping up the temperature to 80 for the
last day of winter so that by the time
spring arrives at 8 33 sunday morning
we're going to end up with a high only
in the 60s for the first day of spring